the 20th century was all about
hierarchies if you want to create
something if you want to if you want to
start a country create a product
whatever it is your goal is to is to
create a highly efficient hierarchical
model scale it because that's what the
competition is doing and whoever does
that the largest and one the most
efficiency will eventually dominate the
market will be the dominant country
however you want to look at everyone
played this some version of this game
21st century is dominated by networks
because the introduction of the
information age we can suddenly create
free flow these globally distributed
organic shaped networks of individuals
it's a radically different environment
for everyone that translates into into
any space that you can imagine really
everyone's wrestling with some version
of this because we grew up in the in the
bureaucratic model and so we're trying
to change not just the way we act but
our psychology and how we view the world
and it's going to change the battlefield
as well you know it's inevitable that
tech the technology curves continues to
grow exponentially one of the majors
we're seeing that is the debate around
unmanned vehicles so is is is a
completely robotic battlefield out of
the question at some point no I think
it's at a question not to think about
that as a as a possible end state we're
so on the front edge of these debates
that it'll be laughable I'd imagine 100
years from now but we're the fascinating
part is if you look at the discussions
around this type of technology for the
most part nation states are still trying
to solve it through their traditional
bureaucratic thinking how do I legislate
for this what does it look like etc etc
and there there's going to just be an
exponential change and how this affects
but has the real effects on the ground
as the technology continues to grow so
now we have you know you know a single
predator type overhead aircraft unmanned
that can do you know XYZ a very very
significant group jump over the past 20
years fast-forward that 20 years and
that as the technology scale can
continues to increase exponentially that
could be a single aircraft that has a
network of thousands around it that are
real-time monitoring you know on the
ground in the air buildings whatever the
case may be where the technology is
pushing conflict is moving so much
faster than our system's ability to
adapt and regulate it that is going to
be real real challenge for us in the
next 10 to 15 years